a un año crucial y desafiante así se
perfila el 2022 para emanuel marcó con
el primer día del año ya llegó un gran
reto su presidencia rotativa de la unión
europea que catalogó como un punto de
inflexión para pasión dominio a partir
de la medianoche francia asumirá la
presidencia rotativa de la unión europea
y pueden contar con mi compromiso total
a pesar de su optimismo marco deberá
liderar al bloque europeo inmerso en un
complejo panorama con la crisis
sanitaria que sigue azotando a europa y
la reciente escalada de la atención
entre ucrania y rusia aún así parece que
el presidente tiene sus principales
objetivos claros buscará el
establecimiento de salarios mínimos en
toda europa la regulación de los
gigantes digitales y la creación de un
impuesto al carbono además de la
protección de las fronteras europeas
frente a las crisis migratorias un
liderazgo que podría haberse afectado
por su propia pugna presidencial el
mandatario no ha anunciado aún su
candidatura que muchos ven como
ineludibles un gesto que podría deberse
a su deseo de no mezclar sus decisiones
políticas con su campaña presidencial su
carrera por hacerse de nuevo con él y ya
tiene un importante obstáculo la
candidatura de la conservadora valérie
pécresse es su principal rival que se ha
afianzado en una parte del electorado
mi deseo por tanto es que en la próxima
primavera las elecciones presidenciales
sean de convicciones y verdaderas
soluciones para francia cerca de dos
años de pandemia han golpeado duramente
al mandatario que además de seguir
lidiando con el aumento de los casos
deberá luchar contra la caída de su
popularidad